i don't want to lose more time here over
to you
madam president you have the floor
thank you so much libra wolfgang is
ladies and gentlemen
indeed i vividly remember how two years
ago joe biden promised
at the munich security conference we
will be back
and indeed we've just seen it heard it
the us is back
and as we've also just heard more
globally committed than ever
this commitment couldn't come at a
better time
how we come out of this crisis will have
profound
consequences for our citizens for our
economies
and also for the position of our common
alliance
in the post-covet world and let me
give you two examples for what could be
driving our new global agenda
the first example is climate change
climate change is the looming crisis
behind covet
and the loss of biodiversity is a main
driver of today's
and potentially future pandemics
more than a year ago europe has said
that it wants to become the first
climate neutral continent by 2050
and with our european green deal we want
to reduce greenhouse gas emissions
by at least 55 already by 2030
but to successfully fight global climate
change
we need others to match our ambition
and they do from south korea to japan
from south africa to china and we are
really excited that president biden
rejoined the paris agreement
on his very first day in office
because the united states is our natural
partner for global leadership on climate
change
and i'm sure a shared transatlantic
commitment
to a net zero emissions pathway by 2050
would make climate neutrality a new
global benchmark and it would be
a timely message in the run-up to the
cop 26
the next u.n climate change conference
to be held in glasgow later this year
we've just heard it i also commend
president biden's initiative to host
a climate leaders summit on earth day
because now is the time for action
and this is also true when it comes to
the digital world
and the impact it has on our democracies
and this is my second example
the storming on the us capital was a
turning point
for our discussion on the impact social
media have on our democracies
this is what happens when words incite
action
in a world where polarizing opinions are
the most likely to be heard
it is only a short step from crude
conspiracy theories
to the death of police officers
in december the commission launched the
digital services act and the digital
market act
our new framework for the digital market
and of course imposing democratic limits
on the uncontrolled power of the big
tech companies
alone will not stop political violence
but it is an important step at its most
basic
we want to make sure that what is
illegal offline is also illegal
online and we want clear requirements
that internet firms take responsibility
for the content they distribute promote
and remove because we just cannot leave
decisions
which have a huge impact on our
democracies
to computer programs without any human
supervision
or to the board rooms in silicon valley
and the latest decision on facebook
regarding australia
is just another proof for that
today i want to invite our american
friends
to join our initiatives together
we could create a digital economy
rulebook that is valid worldwide
a set of rules based on our values
human rights and pluralism
inclusion and the protection of privacy
we need to join forces and protect these
values
with all our energy
ladies and gentlemen a more and more
assertive china has shown robust
economic growth in 2020 despite the
pandemic
and the more and more defiant russia
continues to breach international rules
at home and abroad
despite growing protests of its own
citizens
it is up to us the united states and
europe
to strengthen our cooperation again
as proven and trusted partners
as indispensable allies shoulder to
shoulder
because if we lead the way this is not
only about joining forces
this is a signal to the world thank you
thank you very much madam president
thank you very much
uh as you know very well we have this
wonderful program the munich young
leaders which is co-organized by the
kerber foundation
and the first question that we would
like to
to put to you comes from one of our
munich young leaders from carolina
from germany caroline please the
european union and the united states
have a long and fruitful history of
cooperation and it's great to see that
energy back
under president biden however both sides
turned recently inwards
for example by competing against each
other on vaccines
how do you plan to use this new
transatlantic energy
to lead the european union out of the
pandemic into a strong recovery
and to tackle global issues together
with the united states
thank you colleen madam president
thank you thank you very much for this
question
and indeed first of all the story of
vaccinations for me
is not one of competition to the
contrary
it is one of unprecedented cooperation
you might remember last year europe
convened two pledging sessions
with a result of 16 billion euro to
fight covet
and we were joined by more than 40
countries
but also by ngos like global citizen
and foundations like the bill and
melinda gate foundation
or the welcome trust for example and
together
together with who we put in place the
act accelerator
and covax you all know the facility
where high-income countries finance
access to vaccines for low and
middle-income countries
and just two hours ago at the meeting of
the g7
we doubled our funding to kovacs and it
was exciting to see
the pledging of the united states indeed
the united states are back
and europe is also the continent that's
the second
aspect that produces and exports
the most vaccines to the rest of the
world
so this also shows that we are walking
the talk
we are leading by the power of our
example and finally yes you are right
let's commit to invest in a strong
economic recovery
a recovery that is digital and
sustainable
fair and inclusive and you heard
president biden
this is why we in europe just built our
recovery package next generation eu we
call it it's 1.8
trillion euro it is for the european
green deal and digitalization
because it's good for transatlantic
partnership
but it's also most important
for our children's future we are
investing in
because they have a right to a modern
world and a healthier planet
thank you very much i think we have time
for one
last and brief question and i'd like to
go
to the issue of trade
what are your priorities if i may ask
for
the future transatlantic trade agenda
are you in favor for example of taking
another shot at the ttip
or what other low hanging fruit
can you identify out there what's your
proposal
well a trade is a wide subject
where we are having many trade
agreements worldwide
and indeed i don't think that ttip will
be revived
because we will have we we are not there
where
um the united states left us four years
ago anymore
the world has changed the united states
has have changed
and europe has changed but let me also
have a look
at what our our
impact in geopolitics is not only
on the point of trade but also on other
topics
so the european union is an economic
superpower
it is the most important export market
on the us
india south africa russia just to name a
few
and when it comes to africa it's not
china
but europe is the largest economic
partner by far
and we are by the way the number one
global regulator just recently we have
proposed
to set up indeed an eu
us trade and technology council
because we know that those who write
global rules
are the ones who are shaping the future
of their societies
and you heard the president not enough
none of us wants china to do this for us
so i think doing it together shaping our
trade
and technology agenda is the right way
to go a new global agenda
a more globally oriented us and a more
capable europe this is how we can tackle
the challenges
and europe is ready for this thank you
thank you
so much thank you president fonder lion
actually we stay in brussels now
and go from the commission
straight to the president of the
european council
bonjour missouri president president
charles michel
as president of the council
as president of the council i need to
look in this camera right
uh as president of the council mr
president
you have the authority and the mission
to pull together the 27 heads of